so this is Gerald and these are the 10
things that I can't live without
and then I travel everywhere with you
know for me Rolex is Rolex
he's always held that place of you know
superiority of class growing up by
listening everybody rap about Rolexes
you always want one and that's like a
benchmark you know your journey of your
success getting this watch was like a
Holy Grail watch it's the presidential
it's a classy thing that makes me feel
confident every time I look down and
look at my wrist and shake of time this
is my favorite leather jacket it's
pretty much a staple of my wardrobe it's
a Saint Laurent got a few of them got a
little collection ever when I got my
first one I would every single day and
then I had a good friend of mine paint
the back of it and I became the album
cover for my last album so I've been
wearing this one for about a year it's
just my favorite I mean it's got these
patches it's got this nice natural like
distressing to it it feels like
something from the 70s leather jackets
are definitely worth the investment
because it's something you commit to for
more broken and it gets the more
character it has and when it fits you
and it just becomes a staple piece that
represents you
similar to my leather jacket jeans
really kind of tell a story in music you
travel a lot from Australia to New
Zealand all over Europe to I just got
back from Tokyo and I bring a pair of
jeans these are APCs and these have
definitely been through a war I don't I
mean if you have to you can put them in
a bathtub with some wool like dark and
let them soak in there and dry out but
try not to wash them you know I've got a
ton of black skinny jeans that are kind
of like my staple for being on stage
yeah maybe over 100 I don't know it's
kind of like Batman with his suits a
pair of sunglasses is you know pretty
essential
these are saline I wish I was better at
keeping track of them and not losing
them I think it's really about finding a
pair to fit your face and that you know
you can wear it with most anything
[Music]
obviously the iPhone one of the worst
mistakes I ever made was getting a
second iPhone I was gonna hold me give
the number to a couple people and then
everybody got it and now they kind of
just both ring equally I mean I
literally do everything on this phone if
I have an idea throughout the day which
is constantly I just scribble it down in
my notes
of course apps Instagram I'm on all day
much more than I should be they just get
it done these little power beats music
is essential for me I was in a music
hall day long not even only for
listening but also for when I'm working
on a song or approving a mix or somebody
sending me beats you know I got to be
able to listen to that and always be
available to listen this stuff yeah
essentially I take him with me
everywhere a pocket comb and I would
tell you if I made I used to use but
they weren't paying me for it so we made
our own I've been sticking my hair back
probably six or seven years
naturally travel everywhere with a jar
upon it and a comb she can't be out here
looking crazy
[Music]
I try to bring a book with me everywhere
I go I just throw it in my backpack
whenever I travel would have our book
I'm reading at the time I've been
reading the beautiful and Damned v scott
Fitzgerald it's also the name of my new
album throughout the course of the album
I've been reading this book in stages
and there's several parallels to when
the concept of my album and you know the
story of this book every album I try to
approach it all right what am I trying
to say what am I trying to convey what
story am i trying to tell all that
channels into my music and becomes a
story I've been wearing flannel shirts
my whole entire life I grew up in the
Bay Area where it's always like kind of
cold but not really and it's like not
hot either
so flannel is just I get in between you
just thawing the flannel over a t-shirt
put some vans on and that's the outfit
this is a PC this is just a really nice
wool it's a nice pattern nice colorway
it's simple but it's essential
[Music]
so this is my room Ola felt like it's
very silver very sleek very James Bond I
literally live out of a suitcase it's
made out of metal it gets scuffed up and
dented and again it's kind of like the
jeans of the jacket where it kind of has
some character is almost your apartment
you know you learn to live with less the
contents of this suitcase are my
essentials you know it's what you live
with and what you can't live without
these are my essential items everything
that's got character from traveling with
me over the years so these are mine